avec hélène frade à la une bonjour
hélène de volte face de la suède la
volte face oui quand j'ai en plus tout à
l'heure de la suède et de la finlande
provoqué par la guerre en ukraine tout
cela pourrait amener les deux pays
nordiques a renoncé alors politique
historique de non alignement d'après
cents kathak bladet quotidiens suédois
la première ministre finlandaise ça la
marine et son homologue suédoise
magdalena anderson se seraient mises
d'accord lors de leur rencontre hier à
stockholm pour que leurs pays rejoigne
l'otan selon le journal les
sociaux-démocrates en a même décidé de
déposer rapidement la candidature
suédoise qui pourrait être soumise lors
du sommet de l'otan prévu à la fin du
mois de juin à madrid si la finlande et
la suède se décide à postuler
officiellement leur candidature pourrait
être acceptée en un temps record selon
le corriere della sera cité par courrier
international
d'après le quotidien italien l'adhésion
des liquides stockholm serait même une
simple formalité dans la mesure où les
deux pays scandinaves participent déjà
en tant qu'observateur aux exercices
militaires de l'otan et où celle ci a
déjà signalé qu'elle accueillerait à
bras ouverts la suède et la finlande
la finlande et la suède ont leur place
dans le temps confirme de washington
post le quotidien américain estime que
l'agression de l'ukraine par vladimir
poutine s'est finalement retournée
contre lui en augmentant ce qu'il
redoutait à savoir la probabilité que le
temps s'étendent effectivement jusqu'aux
frontières de la russie ne perspective
que les états unis et le reste de
l'alliance devraient saluer selon
journal qui rappelle en moi que cette
candidature des deux pays nordique n'est
pas une mince affaire pour washington
étant donné l'obligation futur de les
défendre contre d'éventuelles attaques
extérieures comme le prévoit l'article 5
du traité de l'otan l'otan que marine le
pen souhaite voir se rapprocher de la
russie en tout cas après la guerre en
ukraine ont longtemps accusé le sel de
mansuétude envers le régime russe la
candidate à la présidentielle française
a exprimé ce souhait dans le cadre de la
présentation de la politique étrangère
qu'elle mettra en oeuvre si elle est
élue une déclaration reprise on le voit
par le quotidien el país qui rapporte
que la patronne de la reine dit aussi
vouloir mettre fin à la coopération
militaire avec l'allemagne en raison de
divergences stratégiques
irréconciliables je la cite notamment
sur le nucléaire et transformer l'union
européenne en est une alliance
européenne des nations aux états unis de
wall street journal souligne que marine
le pen souhaite également retiré la
france du commandement intégré de l'otan
au motif que cette participation porte
atteinte à la souveraineté de la france
et risque de l'entraîner dans un conflit
contre son gré le quotidien américain
voit dans l'ascension de marine le pen
la preuve envoyé à une grande partie de
l'europe que le scepticisme sur la
confrontation avec moscou n'est pas
sanctionné dans les urnes et qu'il
existe des fissures dans le camp
occidental
quant à la coalition occidentale contre
la russie à propos de fissures dans le
camp occidental y en a aussi entre joe
biden qui accusent la dîmière poutine de
génocide et et emmanuel macron qui tente
de calmer tout ça qui dit refuser l
escalade des mots le terme employé par
le président américain avait également
accueilli avec beaucoup de prudence par
le quotidien belge le soir qui demande à
joe biden de fournir la preuve de ce
qu'il avance faute de quoi il
contribuerait à maintenir l'opacité sur
ce qu'ils dénoncent le soir fait
l'hypothèse que le président américain
puisse donner dans la surenchère et la
propagande je cite comme les états unis
l'ont fait lors de la guerre en irak en
2003 et il cite l'écrivain français
albert camus mal nommer les choses c'est
ajouter au malheur du monde le quotidien
français la croix lui site kleen le
mathématicien grec ce qui est affirmé
sans preuve peut être nié sans preuve le
journal reconnaît que le renseignement
américain a fait la preuve de son
efficacité ces dernières semaines mais
prévient que rien ne serait pire que de
décrédibiliser le travail prudent
minutieux des enquêteurs des juges et
des journalistes sur place le travail
prud'hon et minutieux des journalistes
également malmenées en algérie où le
quotidien liberté titre phare de la
presse francophone algérienne
indépendante publie aujourd'hui son
dernier numéro merci et au revoir titre
ce matin le quotidien algérien qui a
porté pendant 30 ans les idéaux de
démocratie de liberté c'est une page
exaltante du métier qui se tourne écrit
le quotidien en dénonçant je cite les
coups de boutoir d'une politique
médiatique pour le mois au style
inefficace et surtout dommageable pour
les intérêts de l'algérie mais elle
annonce qu il pas là dessus après avoir
révélé que le ministère de la défense de
son pays avait fait l'achat damien de
quelque 35000 pilules de viagra un
député brésilien c'était entre autres
par deux gardiennes affirme à présent
que l'armée brésilienne a également
acheté 60 un plan peignant gonflables je
vous laisse regarder sur internet à quoi
ça ressemble c'est effrayant
l'une d'une valeur à j'en perds mon
latin unitaire de dix à vingt mille
euros damian ses prothèses en a coûté
près de 700000 euros total au
gouvernement brésilien je me renseigne
un pardon alors le ministère de la
défense je vous explique pendant ce long
week end sujet du viagra que ces
acquisitions étaient destinés à des
patients atteints d'hypertension
artérielle pulmonaire il n'a pas encore
répondu pour le moment sur le prothèse
pénienne
obligation justifier sans doute par la
nécessité de se tenir au garde à vous
tromper merci beaucoup hélène frade
merci à vous d'avoir choisi france 24 on
se retrouve dans six minutes pour la
suite de paris direct a tout de suite